i feel like it would be appropriate to
tell you a quote by the co-founder of
reddit himself his name is alex ohanian
he's the co-founder of reddit he tweets
the gamestop squeeze is the public doing
what they feel has been done to them
by institutions he goes on to say this
is something
to believe in so the founder of reddit
is basically saying look
redditers i'm behind you this is dope
what you're doing
so the wall street bet uh the wall
street vets community here let me say a
few words about them they are a new
powerful force to be reckoned with
that's for sure
and thanks to technology they have three
major things behind them these are the
three major things
that these redditors these wall street
bets have behind them number one they
got technology right
they got all the information on the
internet and on their phones they could
possibly ever need
the playing field is equal so that's
number one they got information
number two they got communication tools
aka social media
aka this reddit community they got the
internet they can all communicate
efficiently together so those are the
two things they got and number three
they got easy access to the markets
that's exactly
what robinhood is providing with their
free trading platform
so you got information you got
communication
and you got easy access to markets that
is a deadly combination
or a crew of redditors can take on wall
street and they're using those exact
three technology tools let me give you
another quote this is a quote by
chamath palipatia a tough name to say
but one of the smartest guys out there
he says
wall street bets is now the largest
hedge fund
in the world what
except it's completely decentralized and
entirely
democratic this is very reminiscent of
bitcoin
let me explain that to you and why this
whole story is so powerful
he just said this wall street bets
community
on reddit a freaking community on reddit
is now the most powerful
hedge fund in the world do you
understand the ramifications of that
do you understand that this is literally
power to the people
when it comes to investing this is
giving wall street a run
for their own money pretty powerful
stuff so with that being said
here's my take on all this stuff going
on before i tell you how this affects
your money here's my take so what i
appreciate about wall street bets is
they're serving as a check
to these wall street firms they're not
there's going to be some accountability
this is capital
capitalism at its finest this is
basically saying oh you want to do that
here's what we're going to do all right
so we're sick of you throwing your
weight around with no concern for the
individual investor
we have a voice too so respect to the
wall street vets community
for making this type of bold action
happen it's pretty unprecedented
talking about game stock let's talk
about that stock for a second so usually
what happens in this type of situation
because there is history in these types
of situations so basically in a short
squeeze
situation like this is exactly what
happens a short sale they get squeezed
out
the wall street firms have to buy the
stock price back at a much higher price
um usually what ends up happening is the
stock ends up falling back
to where it came from before all the
drama started
and we have a case example with
volkswagen back in 2008
they were actually the most valued
company on the entire stock market
obviously things have come back to
reality volkswagen is doing what they do
but they're no longer the most highest
value stock on the stock market
so that's exactly what i think is going
to happen with game stock i think their
stock
is going to fall back to reality so
history suggests
that no stock can go up forever and over
time the stock price generally
reflect the future earnings of a company
aka the price
earnings ratio so that's exactly why i
think gamestop
is essentially a manipulated stock it's
been inflated and its stock
will come down eventually if not already
but i also predict that wall street bets
they are not
done anytime soon they have now taken
their attention
to silver and silver is trading at
basically decade high
um that's where silver is at right now
and
quote me on this i think that they're
going to move next onto bitcoin
so bitcoin might be the new darling of
this new wall street bets community
subreddit account
you